Село Баркасово на Закарпатті -
усього за кількадесят кілометрів від кордону з Угорщиною.
Саме в цьому регіоні мешкають більшість українських ромів.
Переважно вони ледь зводять кінці з кінцями, адже роботи тут майже немає.
І все ж дедалі більше ромів повертаються сюди з великих міст -
попри наявні там кращі можливості заробітку.
Причина - побоювання стати жертвою насильства з боку праворадикалів.
Краще без роботи, але у безпеці з родиною, аніж в страху далеко від дому.
На відео, знятому у квітні цього року, роми втікають від праворадикалів,
які напали на їхній табір у Києві.
Це не поодинокий випадок.
Погроми почастішали у всій країні.
Під час одного з таких нападів наприкінці червня у Львові було вбито 23-річного Давида Папа.
Нападники у масках нанесли ромові понад десяток ножових поранень.
Неповнолітніх підозрюваних взяли під варту.
Втім ці трагічні події викликали обурення передусім за кордоном.
Реакцій на погроми ромів в самій Україні довгий час не було.
Утім, як могло дійти до такого сплеску ненависті й насилля?
І що нині відбувається з тими, хто вижив?
У Баркасовому, де виріс та закінчив школу загиблий,
тепер з пересторогою ставляться до прибулих чужинців.
Лише завдяки супроводу старости та пастора місцевої церкви Живого Бога
Федора Варги DW вдається потрапити до ромського поселення.
Варга як посередник допомагає нам поспілкуватися з удовою Давида Папа - Ібойєю.
Жінка вперше відкрито говорить про вбивство свого чоловіка.
Як і багато інших у поселенні, українською вона майже не володіє.
Основна мова спілкування тут угорська, тож Федір Варга перекладає.
Коли оці молодики пішли на будку, ну, ви знаєте, напевне,
вони відразу, ні слова не сказавши, почали їх ображати, колоти ножами.
Жінка розповідає, що благала не чіпати їх, адже були там разом з дітьми.
Проте це спонукало молодиків з іще більшим завзяттям орудувати ножами.
Мій чоловік лежав мертвий переді мною - більше я нічого не пам'ятаю, каже жінка.
Сама вона, за її словам, втратила свідомість.
У той самий день, коли знімальна група побувала в селі, відгукнулася і львівська поліція.
Ібойю запросили дати свідчення під час процесу в суді.
Однак удова відмовляється, бо дуже боїться.
Чи справді обґрунтовані страхи ромів і чи дійсно українські політики
нарешті почали всерйоз сприймати проблему,
ми запитуємо у заступника голови Закарпатської облдержадміністрації.
На Закарпатті нападів на ромів поки не скоювали,
однак ніде-інде в Україні не живе так багато ромів, як тут.
Якби була жорстка реакція правоохоронних органів на перші напади,
які ще не були з трагічною розв'язкою, точно не сталося б такого вбивства у Львові.
Має бути дуже жорстка реакція в першу чергу правоохоронних органів
і в другу чергу органів влади, щоб вони дали зрозуміти суспільству,
що ці речі будуть викорінюватися з самого початку.
Задовольняючи бажання ромської громади,
поліція на Закарпатті тепер посилено патрулює місця проживання меншини.
Таким чином сподіваються уникнути нових нападів.
Утім, здебільшого роми і далі можуть покладатися лише на самих себе.
В Управлінні праці та соціального захисту населення в Ужгороді
працює Мирослав Горват - представник ромів та місцевий політик водночас.
Що вже доволі рідкісний збіг.
Сам Горват використовує це, аби бути свого роду посередником
між ромською громадою та місцевими органами управління.
Зі своїми проблемами до нього приходять численні місцеві роми,
в яких навіть не завжди є паспорт.
Віднедавна до Горвата дедалі частіше звертаються також і жертви нападів.
Дивно, розумієте, тому що ніколи цього не було.
Ця ненависть, оця відкрита форма дискримінації.
Ці напади, розумієте - оцього ніколи не було.
Якщо ми говоримо про ромську проблему, давайте її вирішувати.
А ми, знаєте: ну, завтра, завтра - з одних виборів на інші вибори…
Разом з Мирославом ми відвідуємо ще одне ромське поселення -
Радванку, що на околицях Ужгорода.
Тут живе 54-річна Клара, яка теж стала жертвою нападу на ромський табір 9 травня на Львівщині.
Там били і старих, і молодь.
Швагеру там голову розкололи, так що він у лікарні лежав.
Вони добивали, думали, що він помер, залишили і так пішли.
Ми не хочемо, щоб їх судили, бо то тюрма, знаєте,
тюрма людину не зробить доброю. А то діти.
Таку думку нам доводиться чути тут не раз.
Через страх подальшої ескалації чи через примирення - зрозуміти важко.
Раптом здіймається переполох.
Хтось пограбував церкву по сусідству.
Поліція відразу ж підозрює ромів.
Вони все віддадуть.
Там просто вони залізли в приміщення у церкву, зламали…
А є фотографії?
Як завершилася ця історія, ми не знаємо.
Принаймні поліція залишила Радванку, нікого не затримавши.
Насправді людям тут, як ніколи, потрібний захист.
Проте відносини з владою напружені і сповнені недовіри, нарікає Мирослав.
Інформаційна складова, яка існує в інтернеті, - це великий негатив.
Хто украв? - Роми украли.
Хто біду наробив? – Роми наробили біду.
Це ненормально.
На сьогоднішній день ми дуже потребуємо захисту від влади.
Так, як ніколи.
Тому що якщо говорять про ті громадські організації, які нападають на ромів,
ми не впевнені, що, можливо, завтра буде в Ужгороді.